troisième journée de tournage à hong
kong le temps file vraiment ça cher
notre voyage ici on est dans un quartier
commercial touristique quelque chose
beaucoup d'animations même le soir parce
que il est presque 9 heures mais il ya
beaucoup de monde dans les rues en fête
les magasins ferment plus tard certains
10 heures 11 heures minuit et s'il ya
beaucoup de gens dans les rues c'est que
probablement les appartements ici sont
extrêmement petit donc les gens
préfèrent être à l'extérieur
alors d'abord retour en arrière parce
qu'hier soir on pensait avoir terminé
notre journée travail mais on a appris
qu'il y avait des centaines de
manifestants masqués qui était barricadé
dans une gare de train en fait il
voulait souligner qu' il y à un mois
il ya des membres des gangs de hong kong
qu'on appelle ici les triades qui s'en
sont pris très violemment à des
protestataires qui revenait d'une
manifestation pourtant pacifique
il y avait des policiers à l'extérieur
on craignait qui est
vos de la confrontation mais finalement
il y en a pas eu tout s'est bien terminé
heureusement aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on
a fait il y avait une autre
manifestation des jeunes cette fois des
jeunes du secondaire qui manifestaient
justement contre la violence policière
manifester très pacifiquement un sit in
au centre ville on est allé prendre
quelques images de ça j'ai réalisé en
fait que les gens sont très jeunes
il ya des gens de 11 12 13 ans dans ces
manifestations
ils me disent qu'ils participent aussi
non seulement à ces manifestations
pacifiques mais aussi à celles qui sont
plus violentes
alors eux aussi semblent déterminés
c'est quand même impressionnant de voir
ça ensuite on a fait des entrevues
parce que des entrevues plus longue avec
un éminent sinologue qui enseigne à
l'université de pékin
jean pierre cabestan qui nous a donné un
peu le contexte historique
les raisons plus profondes de ces
manifestations de ce mouvement de bonté
passion est ce que vous savez quand on
arrive ici on connaît un peu la
situation
mais c'est toujours utile pour nous de
parler à des gens qui sont des experts
et qui vont nous permettre un peu de
mieux vous raconter cette histoire
l'autre entrevue qu'on a fait c'est avec
un québécois qui vit ici depuis 40 ans
s'appelle bernard puyol donc un homme
d'affaires qui avait une compagnie ici
qui est maintenant à la retraite mais
qui nous a donné aussi son point de vue
sur l'évolution de la situation et il
nous a parlé de l'importance économique
de hong kong pour la chine parce qu'il
dit que encore au fond c'est un peu le
pari le londres
le new york des chinois donc une région
encore très importante
et selon lui c'est peut-être sans doute
pour ça qu'il n'y a pas d'intervention
policière parce que ça serait vraiment
catastrophique pour enfants alors donc
cette entrevue
et ben c'est ainsi que notre notre
tournage s'achève en fait on a à peu
près tout ce qu'il nous faut pour notre
reportage
ça m'a fait plaisir de partager un peu
les dessous de notre travail avec vous
là maintenant on prends l'avion demain
on rentre à montréal pour faire le
montage et si tout va bien pour si
jamais avec notre avec notre dans notre
métier comment tout peut se terminer
mais si tout va bien on vous présente ce
reportage donc lundi soir ôtez les
jambes